retired Admiral Mike Mullen was chairman
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff from 2000
to 7 to 2011 under Presidents Bush and
Obama Admiral good morning good morning
sir
you hear president Trump this morning
calling this a witch-hunt the special
counsel is Bob Miller who is widely
respected correct what do you make of
this well I think the the selection of
Muller is just terrific he is widely
regarded he's got of clear independence
he's got a history of being able to
conduct these kinds of investigations
and I think for where we are in it it's
really important to get the bottom of it
and there's nobody better suited to do
that than Bob is there any doubt in your
mind that we will get to the bottom of
it
no I think he will I mean it's it's hard
to know with all of the discussion on
both sides of this issue that that'll
happen let's say quickly but I got a lot
of faith in him
and his background that he'll be able to
do that you know Washington you know the
players in Washington what is going on
with this president I just think it's
it's so so polarized that just one issue
after another just keeps coming out and
I actually I don't have a lot of problem
with the president and the
administration disrupting DC because I
think it has not functioned well for a
long time that said there has to be
processed there has to be a way to get
through the issues in some reasonable
way that disruption is mainly about
gridlock yeah well no I mean but III
think that clearly there is obviously
one issue after another and to the
degree that the administration feels
that it's under siege that they keep
generating the crises that will you know
national security true and that's where
the questions are coming from and Russia
well and no end
yeah well I mean that we have to have
focus in that area we have to have
consistency in that area and and it
seems to be there's just one
self-generated crisis after another
coming from the White House but the
president says it is his right to have
the conversations that he wants to have
in the Oval Office HR McMaster said the
other day that the conversation with
Russian officials was wholly appropriate
it do you agree with their take on that
well I worry a great deal about
revealing intelligence particularly to
the Russians that the president has the
right to do that there's no question
about that but it's an apparently
incredibly sensitive intelligence and we
just have to be really careful about
that and it seemed as if it were
released almost instantly as opposed to
a well thought through
beyond Russia there's a question of the
Middle East and the president is going
therefore to Saudi Arabia what's
possible and what does he have to do
well I think he's got to establish a
relationship and I don't expect a
tremendous amount out of this trip in
terms of major decisions but having a
relationship that's strong and engaging
with Saudi Arabia and other Middle East
leaders is really critical make a big
speech on Islam right all these Islamic
leaders are going to be there right well
I think again that gets back to or gets
to the point of connecting with them
letting them know that we care about
them and having and having having a
relationship with them at a time of
great concern for them do we need a new
change in policy in fact to disrupt the
previous policy because of their sense
of whether they can depend on American
those other issues well I think that
that issue of dependence is absolutely
critical and I won't say a new policy
but certainly a reengagement I know that
the Arab leaders have felt left out in
recent years and from that standpoint
this engagement is really critical how
important is it for the White House and
the intelligence community to have a
good working relationship because right
now it seems so very fractured and it
seems the president today is even
doubling down on that I think it's
absolutely critical and and then the
president the new administration has had
its ups and downs with the intelligence
community they've focused tremendously
on leaks my own experiences in
Washington the harder you chase leaks
the more leaks they're going to be they
need to be on the same page and they
need to have confidence and trust why is
that important we all think that but why
is that important because my one worry
is that if you you know continue to
press exceptionally hard on the
intelligence community and the what the
president said the other day that very
sensitive piece of information the worry
is that they
might the Intel community may start
pulling back on what they share with the
president North Korea toughest problem
that confronts us right now that could
go south very very rapidly very
dangerous a very unpredictable leader
young with nuclear weapons
give the administration credit for
moving the Chinese at least apparently
relatively quickly nobody else has been
able to do that we'll see if the Chinese
can deliver on making that place
stabilizing that part like to have you
at the table thank you what's going on
since you've left Washington DC he's not
far away you are not far away that's
right